today's topic the boys over at fresh and
fit decided to stop screaming bury it
and uh
posted something on their community page
as an apology fresh and fit we apologize
to our supporters
from this point forward we are not going
to engage in any beef
we are here to help you guys navigate
with women fitness and finances not
drama
we're going to keep giving you guys the
content you subscribe for we apologize
from deviating but we're back on track
men already get attacked enough in the
space and we are not going to contribute
to it
best of luck to have been preaching
their future endeavors see you guys
tonight for fresh and fit after hours
what do you think about their apology
they apologize to their supporters
he didn't apologize to me
or my wife or my country later that same
evening real quick guys okay because uh
i know this is probably on everyone's
minds we already got six thousand plus
live viewers so thank you so much for
coming in four minutes yeah only yeah
seriously within four minutes so guys
we'll talk about this real fast
on this podcast we talk about
accountability okay yeah and we are not
above taking accountability and i'm
gonna tell you guys right now we made a
mistake okay it is not cool to insult a
man's country and or wife live on air we
should have kept the disagreement on the
topic and not the people yep okay smart
people discuss ideas stupid people
discuss people and we made them sick all
right so with that said we apologize
okay for talking about his wife his
country and making ad hominem attacks on
them their fellow youtubers if we have
disagreements we're gonna have
disagreements but the way we went about
it was not right okay yeah so we gotta
hold ourselves accountable as well
and from this point forward we're
bearing the hatchet we wish the best
stop and preach yeah the best man we're
gonna keep making content giving you
guys what you want and we're gonna stay
away from the drama that being said the
boxing you got our number hit us up on
the side you know where we're at we're
in miami so let's do it yeah you didn't
even do that you proposed a fight talk
[ __ ] then when the person accepted
you're like i'll bring 500 000
i offered you 20 000 to just show up win
or lose you were going to get paid hand
you the check beforehand and you still
cowered up talking about know we need to
get promoters you know
these guys think everything is about
money this ain't about money and i'ma
say this to you guys i don't play with
violence it's why you've never heard me
preach come on here and say we would
fight some people you've never heard me
and priests go here we would start some
stuff because where we come from we
understand that's a real thing you don't
play with violence you don't threaten
violence you don't encourage it it's not
something you take willy-nilly just do
with the wrong people and you'll get
called for it y'all were the ones
talking crazy i'll box any of these guys
i'll do it i'll do
[Music]
[ __ ] out of here man you guys were the
one talking crazy and that's how i know
you guys are soft
you talked all that craziness trying to
act out oh hold me back homie nobody's
holding you back preach that he would
take both of you guys because he feels
some type of way and you still got
nothing to say hey and preach i
guarantee your your wife is probably
ugly i said it
yo you gave her a ring pop and you
licked her at your [ __ ] wedding we
should we should fly around bro weirdo
hey yo we should fly her up guarantee
her
flute out
you may kiss the pride this dumb ass
[ __ ]
you're making some dumb ass
we [ __ ] help guys make money we help
guys get in shape we help men improve
what the [ __ ] are you dumbass [ __ ]
doing behind your shitty ass road
shotgun mike
i could tell you [ __ ] think from the
[ __ ] video i'm watching right now
y'all be sweating in the [ __ ] studio
and y'all standing mad awkwardly close
to each other talking to that shitty ass
mike hey we're gonna take on this preach
the [ __ ] man you got one [ __ ] like
clifford bro yeah i wanted a chat oh god
i don't want it what else we will roast
you guys shout out to the freshman
family you guys are not as charismatic
you guys repeated it multiple times when
you thought you were on top right did
y'all got more views right so you better
and all that stuff you got the more
power the perceived perception of that
you want to talk all crazy
and all of a sudden when you realize
that power's not there now you want to
act a little bit humbled it's too late
now you want to see someone's character
give them power and then watch how they
treat the less fortunate and you go
understand how they move y'all never see
me talk to somebody with low subscribers
like they're like they're trash or the
riffraff never i've never done that i do
ig lives every day every day people show
up and i have long conversations i don't
care
because it's not about that but these
guys you see what they're about and now
they want to charge two thousand dollars
for courses meet and greets all these
other nonsense while they're lying and
faking their whole lifestyle nah i got
people in my dms other creators like
maybe we handled this behind why would i
handle it behind the scenes you think i
want to have a one-on-one conversation
with somebody who doesn't believe in the
things that they're saying you were loud
about it why do i have to be private you
were loud about this all of this you
were loud about me you were loud about
my wife you were a lot about my country
you were loud about boxing i didn't
bring this you did you were allowed
about it you handled i would like why
would i do it in private
you brought that there you go you
brought when you open your mouth
go ahead when you open your mouth
there's consequences to the open your
mouth like that that's what real men do
what did you say you said i was 40
exactly
back in my day you could open with that
you could open your mouth like that and
say stuff like that to people because it
might happen you can't do that in prison
you can't talk [ __ ] like that
if you talk [ __ ] about the guard they're
going to ask you to do something about
now you were extra loud
extra extra loud you want to talk loud
and be extra extra be real about it
there's always going to be a
[ __ ] that's going to be realer
than you always know that
you wanna do this
i was right here
i'm still here you know what they said
oh i'm gonna be here here you know what
they said they said why would we do a
two versus one that doesn't make sense
no i'm gonna take one [ __ ] and the
other [ __ ]
you guys are two [ __ ] twin sisters
that's your new name not fresh and fit
twin sisters let's go
these guys turn change their tune once
they saw subscribers going down that's
how you know they lack principle they're
so caught up in numbers they changed
what they said they deleted their videos
they deleted everything right
just because they lost subscribers you
want to stand behind a man you want to
call this out you only stayed behind
numbers yo how long have we been at 1.38
for the past three [ __ ] months yeah
it is what it is who cares we haven't
grown that much it is what it is does it
matter not really it didn't matter when
we had 300k it didn't matter we are 69k
y'all notice the outro still says 69k
because it's all the same that's the
worst part we never change the outro
look at the [ __ ] outro it says 60
whatever now you know what kills me you
know what kills me people mad well why
would you make the video in the first
place y'all ain't got nothing to say
when we cover skippy or any other
individual and we go at it like that
then it's these dudes they invited you
in their home no they begged us to come
on a podcast with them don't get it
twisted they're not friends i gotta
receive texts i got their okay and i
hold everyone accountable if you say
something crazy online i'm not gonna
call you in private okay unless it's a
private matter they publicly said some
stupid [ __ ] so we said let's dissect
that stupid stuff but now because it's
your hero oh ab or like two-face what's
two-faced i went on that podcast and i
went right to myron's face because he
was talking crazy on another podcast you
know what i told him why were you saying
that stuff he started stuttering i don't
remember calling you blue pill beta
specifically you felt like we were kind
of blue filled right uh i don't remember
what show what show was this one i
remember very very well because that
episode i was very careful of what i
said because it gives you questions damn
so i was very careful of what i said
because
[ __ ] so i just want to ask you about
that why do you think i might be blue
built um well from what i remember i'm
trying to remember i would say uh
like
hmm i'm trying to i'm trying to think
like which video was
it was this one i'm trying to remember i
said i quoted it right to his face even
even the goofy fresh boy he was like oh
abba came with the smoke i also find it
funny he came with the smoke the idea
that i wouldn't come to people and
confront them about things they say are
you guys mad
but don't ever come out here talking all
this stuff just say you're a fanboy and
you can't help sin for them i'm not mad
at it everyone when i was a kid batman
was magic everyone's like superman's
better i said [ __ ] no even though
superman
got laser beam coming out his eyes
obviously he's better but i get it you
know i mean that's that's batman
clark kent
what superman's stupid
stupid character definitely better
stronger
but he's stupid agreed
i'm not a fan of clark kent it's like
come on b but he's still stronger
yeah but if he's not he's not wise
enough to use it goku is not the
strongest character because he's stupid
i mean goku is pretty lucky but that's a
different story
so if they say some more dumb stuff in
the future we're going to cover it the
same way we covered skippy the same way
covering amanda's seals certainly
covered anybody i like phil defranco
phil defranco said some dumb [ __ ] we
covered it period it ain't two-faced all
right so
you all do you we got more videos of
y'all we're gonna react to we're gonna
keep deconstructing the stupid [ __ ]
y'all say and if y'all want to stop
watching stop watching i don't care tell
us what you guys think do you guys agree
with their apology disagree with us and
the way we're handling it we'll listen
to everybody i'll also be on ig in a
little bit so you have to tell us what
you'll be on a little bit we can do that
well i'll be on i'll be in miami next
week
[Music]
foreign
now